[Applaus]
weltkrieg potter praktiker herzlich
willkommen zu diesem jahr wieder leute
ich mache dieses video denn auf youtube
deutschland passiert gerade eine sache
über die wir reden müssen und zwar etwas
passiert was sie auch die youtube
deutschen passiert und zwar haben
deutsche youtuber die amerikanischen
über folgen gesehen dass in der regel
gerade irgendwie in trend am laufen ist
und zwar der cutting people's earphones
trend bei dem es darum geht dass man
halt irgendwie angeblich zu üblichen
trend hingeht und die komplette
durchschneidet und den halt irgendwas
presse das wie ein kopfhörer gibt
meistens airports also ich heute diesem
video disco jahren wird 40 millionen
aufrufe da wird er alle anderen
deutschland sich gedacht haben
mamma mia das mache ich jetzt auch und
genau das ist passiert ich habe den
grenzen wieder gesehen platz 9 von
fabian magic ich zerstöre fremden die
airports und schenke ihnen erfolgsfrau
ich habe dann dieses video reingeschaut
und dass man recht schnell aufgefallen
dass ich ja darüber der reaktion machen
muss warum werden wir gleich sehen also
der anfang ist schon direkt war richtig
gut so so wird der fall beginnt klaus
seine er trotz der sich wahrscheinlich
hart erarbeitet hat für uns eine stunde
und von 10 euro oder so schmeißt sie weg
und wisst ja ich hasse apple produkte
ach so ich wurde gerade eine reinhauen
aber wenn du erste produkte hast dann
ist natürlich auch der christen benutzen
ist also schwäbischen akzent als
cannabis gedreht ist vielleicht ein
stuttgarter sowie kannst du eigentlich
apple produkte benutzen wichtig auch die
sache ist noch leute es gibt ziemlich
genau zwei art und weise wie dieses
video entstanden sein könnte und beide
sind nicht so gut nummer eins ist dass
die leute halt einfach involviert sind
sodass es abgesprochen ist so sieht es
für mich nämlich aus weil so die sie ist
auch nicht so verdammt das sowas sollte
scheint sowieso nummer zwei wäre hat
dass diese videos wir sind und ich weiß
nicht was wirklich besser ist einfach
sofort zu mit fremden eigentum so
umzugehen dass video heißt ja ich
zerstöre fremd
die airports und schenken airports pro
pro was ist wenn ich airports pro
hässlich finde leute nicht die kopfhörer
wegnehmen und dann wegschmeißen
also klingt abenteuerlich aber
vielleicht dass er versucht ihr so
rational zu erklären warum er das macht
so ja ja ich mag halt nicht apple
produkte sowie verstehst und nicht warum
ich da eine kopfhörer gerade
weggeschmissen haben es musste doch
nachvollziehen können also ja ja ja ja
egal
ja gut wie kein geld für neuer ist lasse
ich bezahlt war nochmal warte mal ich
hab was besseres wo ist das neue abo
rausgekommen sind ja schon mal
ich habe hier neue airports po und die
die schenke ich dir ein versteckter
kamera also leute ich weiß ich weiß
nicht wie ihr seht aber das sieht sehr
sehr sehr scripted für mich aus als
wären die leute die man hier sieht auf
jeden fall mit einbezogen also ich
zumindest genau diese reaktion und
nachvollziehen so wenn mir auf der
straße jemand meine airport aus dem ohr
nehmen würde und die wegschmeißen würde
würde ich zumindest seine komplette
familie erst noch beleidigen wenn ich
ihn sogar eine reinhauen und diese so ja
also verkrümelt es wohl könnte das kann
es vielleicht machen die sache ist vor
allem leute guckt mal so sehen normal
airports ausweisen nicht missen
und so sehen die airports pro aus okay
die kosten
warum er das stimmt aber vielleicht
wollen leute ist einfach nicht
vielleicht finden leute die hässlich so
ich persönlich finde die normalen 20.000
mal geil aus als airports browser aber
siehst du sahel tut mir leid was ich
gerade gesagt haben du sind gerne meine
ganze familie und mich von vorne bis
hinten nehmen wir alles weg was ich habe
so lange wir nach ein paar posco
bekommen ist alles super für mich
tatsächlich glauben ich wäre auch total
ausgerastet weil makler evtl normalfall
[Gelächter]
also ist firma weil er meinte er wäre
auch total ausgerastet ja genauso wie
sie total ausgelassen also einem aber
das sieht schon sehr abgesprochen aus
weil ich sie ein bisschen dreckig aus
china was du machst das ist auch keine
echte reaktion
er nimmt ihm seinem erfolg vor seinen
augen wie sehr kann man jemanden
verarschen vor seinen augen nimmt er den
airport und aus den in die wasserflasche
rein und schüttelt die dann noch und er
das erst geklaut wurde bisher weiß was
hier gerade mal noch eine rein
die situation ist absurd aber
wahrscheinlich lacht jemand wenn man ihm
sein eigentum wegnimmt und kaputtmachen
seinen augen ist lustig dass ich gerade
folgen fängt ja also ich wollte nur
gefallen tun weil ich persönlich sehe
ein bisschen dreckig aus ganz europa
jetzt machen sie so rum
das wäre weniger absurd als dass jemand
lacht wenn man seine airports vor seinen
augen kaputt macht die sache ist heute
dieser trend ist natürlich auch in
deutsch und mega groß
dieser vater magic hat ein video mit 3,3
millionen aufrufen wohl fremden fremden
die kopfhörer zerschneidet und den
airports schenkt ich kein fake ich kate
aber die airports nicht dreckig weiter
aus die sache ist wollen so die teile
überleben so was vielleicht sogar mir
ist hat sich mal einer
wisst ihr fast immer auf insgesamt
folgte das keiner bleibt mir ist dass
ich mal einer ins klo reingefallen
ohne scheiß bunte unter wasser ist
sauber was aber ich wollte raus
trockenen hat funktioniert schau mal ich
mach dir ein bisschen sauber wer bitte
schön sind die sauberen die müssen wir
nochmal zeit reinigen also die schule
jetzt mal knallige gibt spiel kurz der
kopfhörer nehme die verdichtung macht
die kurze also ohne wenn es nicht
gefahren werden und ich glaube wirklich
dass ich sachen gefällt sind rekord wenn
einer zu mir kommen wir das machen würde
peng voll in die fresse viel spaß damit
siehst du okay das ist okay für mich so
vor dem wo ist der part wo er ihr
airports pro schenkt so sieht wir sind
es willst dass du den leuten dann
zumindest was theoretisch volleres gibbs
das ist so bitter das ist sowas von fake
wer sich genau im richtigen moment
umdreht ohne grund ist fragt damit den
airports auch so wir sagen ja ganz kurz
ganz kurz helgers kurz seine airports
kaputtmachen würde ich nur in eine
wasserflasche schmeißen und sind ist die
original airport oder hasst weil ich
überlegt kann kein zeitung kaufen solle
kann ich mal anhören und die sind vom
klang her
so hat als ob man so einem fremden
einfach seine kopfhörer gibt von sonova
oder sollen auf der straße ansprechen
wie zum ganz fadenscheinigen grund ja
klar mir meine kopfhörer
ich kann ja auch kurz meine kreditkarte
ausleihen wenn du kurz testen möchtest
wie die sich anfühlt in der hand mieter
sind die 20 euro
eigentlich bin dafür jetzt ohne witze
klingen richtig scheiße
ja das nicht sagen kann wir sind jetzt
aber so david sitek ein gerät überhaupt
danke danke dass du mich als wissen
lassen doch mal an der stelle korrekt
von ihren weg weiter fragte also die
sache ist kann es natürlich nicht mit
sicherheit wissen aber ab
wahrscheinlich sie lächelt auch die
ganze zeit so komplett fremder mann
steht in meinem persönlichen space
ungefähr 30 cm vor meiner nase und tritt
auf meinen kopfhörern herum
so baute apple produkte aber hier gebe
ich dir trotzdem ich hasse apple
deswegen also na ja also ja es ist
gleich wieder wir vorhin auch sie sieht
es auch an der stelle auch sehr
verständnisvoll
ach so ich würde jetzt gerade sagen dass
mein freund jetzt kommt und die fresse
einschlägt oder dass du trainer bist
aber hast du für apple-produkte hast
dann können sie nichts machen
schönen tag der noch
jetzt der uni willst also ich mag apple
wirklich nicht naja das alles schwer
wird das alles ganz einfach besser als
ohne witz die marke bildet einfach so
ernst gemeint ach so hat michael
wirklich mich ja dann wie gesagt kann
ich nichts machen alles gut auch sie
bekommen keine airports
sie bekommt auch keine 9 okay okay ich
habe ein bisschen weiter gespuckt heute
also zumindest tut ja am ende noch so
als würde den leuten vom anfang dann
noch airports probleme also aber recht
fix wir können sich mit sicherheit
wissen heute vielleicht sagt fragen
selbst dazu irgendwann was in der
öffentlichkeit aber ich bin mir relativ
sicher dass die ganze sache fake ist was
ist natürlich auch noch ein bisschen mir
damals auch wenn man es dann auch noch
fake leute aber ich finde es richtig
probiert einfach aber jetzt haben wir
auch mal dazu in die kommentare was der
hier ist es fake ist esri und wie wird
ihr reagieren wenn einer euch eure
kopfhörer klauen würde bekommt ihr
natürlich persönlich vorgeschlagen das
video jürgen könnte man kann abonnieren
ich muss sagen macht's gut